Transcriber: Zayd Skaff
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
أريد منكم جميعًا
أن تغلقوا أعينكم لو سمحتم.
أغلقوا أعينكم رجاءًا.
وتخيلوا أنفسكم في قاعة كبيرة
مثل هذه القاعة، فيها أكثر من خمسمائة شخص.
أنت تريد أن تتواصل معهم،
تريد أن تتكلم معهم من أجل أن تبني فرصتك،
وتصطاد مستقبلك،
فستبدأ وتقول: “يا الله“.
كيف سأستطيع أن أتحدث مع كل هؤلاء،
أحتاج أكثر من 500 بطاقة عمل لأوزعها عليهم.
إذا أردت أن أتكلم مع كل شخص دقيقة واحدة،
فإني أحتاج أكثر من 500 دقيقة، أي 8 ساعات.
أي يكون انتهى حديث TEDx
وأنا لا أزال في القاعة.
وتحتاج عندما تعود إلى المنزل لإرسال أكثر
من 500 إيميل؛ لتتواصل معهم كلهم.
افتحوا عيونكم.
هذه للأسف المشكلة التي كلنا نظنها التشبيك.
كيف نشبّك مع الأشخاص الموجودين؟
عندما دُعيت إلى TEDx بدأت أفكر ما الذي
يمكن أن أتكلمه مع الشباب الموجودين اليوم؟
الفكرة كانت أن نتكلم بشيء أنا أتقنه الآن.
وأنا أتقنها كل يوم
وسأشاركها معكم وهي التشبيك.
دعونا نرى معنى التشبيك حسب موقع “ديكشنري“.
يقول “ديكشنري” أن التشبيك هو
عبارة عن مجموعة من الناس تملك نظام دعموي.
وبنفس الوقت يتبادلون المنفعة والخدمات
لأنه يجمعهم اهتمام مشترك.
فالفكرة من التشبيك ليس أن تتكلم مع الجميع
ومع كل شخص موجود.
لا، الفكرة أن تبني أنت شبكتك
بطريقة صحيحة وتجعلها قوية.
إذا أردنا أن نتكلم عن معنى التشبيك
من قاموسي الشخصي فهي انترنت وعمل.
أن تبني أنت شبكتك كل يوم، والشبكة الغعالة
الخاصة بك، لكن تحتاج أن تعمل علها أكثر.
أن تعمل بجهد، وتعطيها وقتتها الصحيح.
عندما يخطر ببالنا كلمة شبكة وكلمة عمل جاد.
قد يكون أول ما يخطر ببالنا هو العنكبوت.
من يحب العناكب هنا؟
تتذكرون عندما كنا صغاراً
دائما ما كنا نغني عن العنكبوت.
نعلم أنه من الحيوانات التي تحب أن تعمل
وتجتهد لتصل لمستقبلها.
أود أن أعرفكم على صديقي “سبايدر“.
من الأشياء الجملية للعناكب أنهم كل يوم
يبنون شبكتهم وبطريقة منظمة
وبطريقة نظامية جداً من أجل أن يصطادوا
المستقبل الذي يريدونه ويصلوا لما يريدون.
والأجمل من ذلك والأغرب
أنهم كل ليلة يعدلون هذه الشبكة.
ويحسنوها لكي يصطادوا المستقبل
في اليوم التالي وليصلوا إلى فرصهم.
لماذا أنا أحدثكم عن العناكب والتشبيك؟
ما الفكرة من الموضوع؟
أنا أن أؤمن أن كل واحد موجود هنا اليوم
لديه عناكب في داخله.
لا تخافوا لم نضع عناكب تحت الكراسي.
الفكرة أننا نحن كلنا لدينا عناكب
وكلنا نبني شبكاتنا الخاصة بشكل يومي.
بطريقة قد لا نكون واعيين لها، لكن الشطارة
والذكاء أن نشبك هذه الشبكات التي بنيناها.
باعتقادي نحن نعيش في ثلاث أنواع من الشبكات
إذا شبكناهم بشكل صحيح،
سنتمكن من الوصول لمستقبلنا وفرصنا.
الثلاث شبكات هي:
شبكة العقل، الشبكة الواقعية وتمثّل الناس،
وهي الشبكة الواقعية، والشبكة الافتراضية
وهي الانترنت والتكنولوجيا.
لنبدأ  بشبكة العقل .
كلنا نعرف أن عقلنا مكون من عدد من الخلايا
العصبية المعقدة التشبيك،
لكن هذه الخلايا نحتاج أن نبنيها كل يوم
ونغذيها بذكاء أكثر .
كيف ؟ عن طريق شيء اسمه التعلم الذاتي
والوعي الذاتي.
التعلم الذاتي والوعي الذاتي.
أتذكر عندما قررت أن أصبح شخص يعمل بالتشبيك
وأخرج عن من مجال الصيدلة ،هكذا شخص صيدلاني
يدرس في مجال الصيدلة يقرأ فقط
كتب الصيدلة وحياته كلها عبارة عن صيدلة،
قررت أن أتغير، أن العالم أكبر من هذا
توسّع في مداركك.
انضممت لجمعية فيها أكثر من، موجودة في أكثر
من مئة وعشرين دولة في العالم
تعرفت على ثقافات مختلفة وعلى لغات مختلفة،
وصرت أتعرف بنفس الوقت على كتب مختلفة.
لم أعد متقوقعاً فقط في مجال واحد،
وصرت أعرف أكثر من لغة.
وأكثر من هوية وأكثر من ثقافة
وأزيد معرفتي ومداركي.
اليوم أنا بقدر أعرف أكثر من مئة وعشرين لغة
وأكثر من مئة وعشرين ثقافة
وأكثر من مئة وعشرين دولة من دون زيارتهم.
هذا أنا في الصورة.
دعونا نتكلم عن الشبكة الثانية التي هي
الشبكة الواقعية، الناس، نحن
نحن كل يوم نضيف ناس لشبكتنا، ونخرج ناس
من شبكتنا، وقد يكون هذا هو الطبيعي.
ونحن نقوم بها بطريقة لا إرادية.
الجميل أن هذه العملية الإضافة والحذف
هي عملية ممارسة وتدريب .
إذاكنت تمارس هذا الشيء، ويجب أن تستمر
بالعمل عليه لتقويه أكثر.
لكن الاختلاف و السر،
أن الناس الذين تضيفهم لشبكتك
أوتخرجهم منها يجب أن يكونوا...
لماذا هم يريدون التشبيك معك؟ ما هو المختلف
عندك انت ولا يدعهم يشبكون مع شخص آخر؟
إذاً ما المختلف عندي
ويجعل الناس تشبّك معي؟
خلال السنوات الماضية
كنت أشبك مع العديد من الأشخاص.
كنت أشبك مع معلمين، مرشدين، مع أشخاص تريد
أن تتعلم وأشخاص جائت لتتعلم،
وكنتأجلس وأعمل مع الكل بشغف وطاقة.
لكن الاختلاف كان أنني كنت أضع نفسي
في دائرة من الأشخاص الملهمين،
لديهم خبرات أفضل مني،
ولديهم طاقات أفضل مني.
لأوسّع نفسي أكثر
ولأظل أعمل على نفسي.
ولا أبقى ضمن منطقة راحتي ومرتاح.
كنت دائما أظل أعمل أكثر وأكثر .
وسع مداركك، هذا الذي أعطاني خبرات أكثر
وجعلني أخرج من مجال الصيدلة التقليدية فقط.
وأبني أشياء مختلفة، ومنها الآن أنني أنشأت
شركتي الخاصة في مجال التدريب والاستشارات.
وأقف أمامكم اليوم بهذا الشيء.
إذا أردنا أن نتكلم عن الشبكة الثالثة التي
هي الشبكة الافتراضية،
الإنترنت ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي .
دعنا نكن واقعيين، نحن اليوم محظوظون جداً
بأننا لدينا الإنترنت وهذه الشبكة
الأجيال السابقة لم يكن عندها هذا الشيء،
نحن في فرصة ثمينة جدا لسنا نقدرها،
نحن نسيء تقدير هذه الفرصة التي بين أيدينا.
لدينا منجم ذهب لا نراه
إلا الذين يرونه.
سأسألكم سؤالاً، كم واحداً هنا منكم اليوم
أمسك الموبايل وصور نفسه
ونشر منشوراً على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
أنه يحضر مؤتمر TEDx مسقط 2019؟ برفع اليد
هذا رائع.
الآخرون لمَ لم تفعلوا ذلك؟
هذه فرصة أن تجعلوا الناس يرون
ما تفعلون وتستغلوا هذا الشيء .
طيب، في 2017 كنت أنا أستخدم
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بطريقة إيجابية،
أنشر أني معكم اليوم في صالة TEDx،
أنا اليوم معكم هنا، نقوم بهذا، نغعل ذاك.
أحد الأصدقاء الافتراضيين
رأيته مرة واحدة في حياتي،
كان ضيفي على وسائل التواصل.
قال صالح أريد أن أراك ونتكلم بموضوع لساعة
لديّ فكرة أريد أن أشاركها معك، حسناً،
ذهبنا جلسنا وشربنا كوب قهوة.
امتد الاجتماع أربع ساعات
طردنا من المكان الذي نحن فيه .
الموضوع أننا خرجنا بفكرة ريادية مبتكرة .
جهزنا باص لفّ المملكة الأردنية الهاشمية
وخرجنا عن موضوع العاصمة .
رأينا حاجة المجتمع .
قررنا أن نساعد الشباب والصبايا في كل
المحافظات لكي يقوموا بمشاريعهم
ويبدأوا مشاريعهم الابتكارية
بطريقة مختلفة وبسيطة .
اليوم هذا الباص تحول لشركة حقيقية
تعمل في أكثر من أربع دول،
وتم تكريمه في 2017
كأحد أفضل المبادرات المجتمعية.
شيء ثانٍ أضافتها إليّ
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي والإنترنت،
أضافت لي مهارة
أدرت مثلاً في يوم أن أحضّر خطاباً
أو أقوم بعرض تقديمي
أو أحضّر أي مشروع.
تجدني أمسكت الموبايل واسأل عن آراء أصدقائي
عدّل هذا وحسّن ذاك،
كل أصدقائي في كل دول العالم
يبدأون بوضع الأفكار والتعديلات.
لم أعد أفكر بمخ واحد فقط.
صرت أفكر
بأكثر من عشرة أمخاخ أو مخوخ أو عقول
بنفس الوقت بسبب التكنولوجيا
ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي.
وأخيراً أنا اليوم واقف أمامكم بسبب
الشبكة الافتراضية .
فريق TEDx تواصل معي عبر الشبكة الافتراضية
وأنا بفخر واقفٌ أمامكم اليوم
ولي الشرف أن أكون معكم.
إذا الفكرة،
لألخص وأختصر،
لنخرج عناكبنا الداخلية.
دعونا نعمل على الوعي الذاتي
والتعلم الذاتي، استمروا بالتعلم.
مارسوا أن تعملوا على
شبكاتكم كل يوم وعليكم أن تكونوا صبورين .
الشبكة لا تبنى بين يوم وليلة ولن تصبحوا
شبكيين بيوم واحد،
تعاملوا مع مختلف أنواع الناس.
تعلموا أكثر.
تعاملوا مع أكثر من نوع وأكثر من شخصية.
اسأل نفسك لماذا يجب أن أكون مختلفاً؟
لماذا ستشبّك الناس معي وليس مع شخص آخر؟
استخدموا وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي والانترنت
بشكل صحيح ومختلف لتصلوا لما تريدون.
ودائما عدّلوا شبكاتكم كما تفعل العناكب.
عدّلها، كل يوم، كل ليلة حسّن شبكتك.
هكذا تستطيع أن تصل لمستقبلك
وتصطاد المستقبل.
أريد أن أطلب منكم طلب لو سمحتم.
الكل يخرج هواتفه .
هواتفكم لو سمحتم
وكلنا نضع إعجاب لـ
حساب انستغرام TEDx.
أكيد أنكم معجبين بالأصل.
حسناً من لم يفعل فليفعل.
أريد أن أعود لبداية الكلام.
قلت لكم نريد أن نشبّك مع 500 شخص
إذاً عملياً أنتم اليوم موجودون مع 500 شخص.
الفكرة إنك الآن بأقل من ثانية.
ممكن أن تختار الشخص الذي تريده.
وتصطاد فرصتك.
وتصل له وتتكلم معه بكل سهولة.
أنتم الآن قادرون أن تشبّكوا مع كل الأشخاص
ولن تحتاجوا ثماني ساعات كما بدأنا.
وإذا أحببتم ضعوا لي إعجاب سأشكركم لن أحزن.
أود أن أنهي الكلام بفكرة صغيرة، تأثير
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي مهم جداً.
لو أنني أريد أن أمسك هاتفي
وأقول لكم أنني أريد أن أشغل الفلاش.
أريد أن أضيء القاعة فقط بالفلاش الخاص بي
أأستطيع؟ لا.
لو طلبت منك أن تمسك هاتفك
وتشغّل الفلاش لو سمحت
جيد، لكن لو طلبت منكم كلكم أن تمسكوا
هواتفكم ونضيء القاعة.
لنتصل كلنا معاً
رائع.
هذه قوة وتأثير التواصل
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي.
قوموا بهذا التأثير
ولن تعلموا من أين ستصطادون مستقبلكم.
تذكروا دائماً، اصنعوا شبكاتكم الخاصة
واتعبوا لأجلها.
وستصطادون مستقبلكم
أنشئوا شبكاتكم الخاصة لتصطادوا مستقبلكم
شكراً جزيلاً لكم
ولن أنس بالتأكيد أن آخذ صورة معكم وأنشر
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي أنني كنت معكم.
جاهزون؟
إذاً، 1,2,3
شكراً جزيلاً لكم.